today we're going to be speaking with
sergey young who is the founder of the
longevity vision fund and also author of
the new book the science and technology
of growing young sergey it's so great to
have you on today
hi david thanks for having me today my
pleasure so
let's just jump right in um i've
recently been reading uh in addition to
your book the book scale by jeffrey west
and one of the things that jeffrey west
talks about is that when it comes to
human aging when you look
mathematically
at metabolic rate and a few other sort
of basic factors it seems as though
the top-end kind of natural life span if
you avoid car accidents and infectious
disease and you know the best scenario
is about 120 years of age now one of the
things i find really interesting about
your book is you start to talk about
this in steps you talk about living to
150. you talk about that so you're not
just jumping in and saying as some do
a thousand years of lifespan is very
very soon on the horizon you're talking
about incremental so talk to us about
that i mean how how do we go from this
natural limit of 100 to 120 up to 150.
perfect great question so
well let's let's start from today what
are the options that we have today to
extend our lifespan so frankly speaking
all of them you know people could call
them boring or my mom told me that so
it's lifestyle changes it's early
diagnostic using power of wearables
technologies this will help us to live
200
healthy and happy years so that's that's
what we can do today from today's
like a stage of development of
technology and science this is actually
pretty important because
we have something exciting in the field
of longevity science and technology
coming to all of us in the next 10 to 20
years within what i call in the book
near horizon of longevity innovation but
it's very important to stay on longevity
breach and be as healthy and happy as
possible so then in 10 20 years time our
body and mind is worth extending its
resource so that's one
and it's like a separate part of the
book it's a bonus chapter is
is
as as
twice as long as any other chapter
there's so many things you can do today
i call it 10 longevity choices
so then the second piece
is a near horizon of longevity
innovation and again this is
technologies and scientific
breakthroughs which will be available to
all of us in the next 10 15 20 years and
when people ask me what are the most
exciting uh from this list i'm always
talking about gene editing and gene
therapy
organ regeneration our ability to regrow
and replace organs inside our body
similar to what we do with the old car
extending its resource and longevity and
appeal in the next 10 years we'll have
a completely new class of drugs which
will focus on aging its core rather than
any particular disease this is the kind
of drugs that we have today so that's
again near horizon of longevity and then
there's something more on the horizon
it's called far horizon of longevity
innovation and i'm talking about
technologies which will be available to
us in the next 25 to 50 years from now
and this is when man and machine will
become one where when we talk about
integration between computer power and
and human intellect and um
without changing the definition of human
it's going to be very difficult to live
beyond 120 or 150 years so okay let's
let's stop there for a second because
that's really important
so
you you seem to be acknowledging
that there is this sort of
metabolic and cellular natural ceiling
to human longevity
that
is going to need some more major change
or intervention in order to be extended
significantly
yes so
what we can do within the current
biological view on the human body
biological perspective has the limit
whether it's 100 or 120 or 130 years
i don't know but it's obviously in this
field so then
we need we would need to complement the
biological perspective and engineering
or technological perspective and look at
the integration of this for us to be
able to live longer but the bigger
question is not the science and not in
technology the biggest question is
ethics
and regulation because we have created
technology to extend our lives david but
we haven't created life that we want to
extend 60 to 80 percent of people in the
world depending on the country would say
no to life extension opportunities so we
will need to sort out a lot of ethical
issues and almost create a new amazing
version of this world and society for us
to embrace the idea of longer living i
call it morality of immortality and this
is my biggest worry this is my biggest
concern this is where we need to have a
conversation about ethical choices
before we embrace the technology
yeah well you know i've interviewed uh
longevity researcher aubry degray
several times over the last 15 or so
years
and he often makes news for the things
that are more
salacious that he says like the first
person to live to a thousand has already
been born or something like that and you
know
maybe that's true maybe it's not but
that what i find more interesting about
what he says are when i bring up the
ethical considerations how triage
considerations change if the upper limit
of life is extended or what is the
economic impact what is the
environmental impact of people living so
much longer he says it sort of will
mostly work itself out like if people
live a lot longer the birth rate will go
down for example what do you think about
that
so i i do believe that there's so many
things that we need to change
in this world for us to be able to enjoy
this far horizon of longevity so a few
of them like
i do believe longevity and longevity
technology has an opportunity to become
a unifying theme for the nation and for
society because
someone need to close an equality gap
which is widening all the time so i my
mission is to bring affordable and
accessible version of digital healthcare
and technology to the world i'm not
interested to create something for the
rich ones right so that's that's one
second is
this whole relationship with mother
nature as you pointed out when you leave
75 years there's always a temptation to
say okay i'm gonna die in 20 years from
now next generations will sort it out
for themselves if you're going to live
120 150 years i do believe that it give
us an opportunity to be much more
responsible in our relationship with uh
with the planet with the mother in
nature
we're gonna face the consequences of our
own actions
or the other thing is and it's probably
the final comment on the ethical side is
um
social constructs
you know these binary social constructs
that we have today like career uh
marriage um retirement they've been
developed in a society where the average
lifespan was 35 years
like two-thirds of the marriages are
going through divorce in the first five
years um
of uh their life
and this is not great and we would need
to come up with a variety of the options
for
you know two people in this world to be
you know to fix their responsibility for
like kids growing
uh or anything else or this whole career
thing a retirement thing it's also
binary it's just you work full-time and
then you like full time retire and two
most dangerous years of your life is the
year of your birth because we still have
this high infant mortality and year of
your retirement because you lose in in
today's binary framework full-time work
full-time retirement people lose the
opportunity for social realization and
this is one of the
most important component of you your
desire willingness and ability to live
longer so we just need to rethink can i
have as many careers as decades in my
life
i need to have an answer to this
question and now society needs to be
ready and and change itself and it's
norm to accommodate this yeah that's a
very interesting social question about
increased lifespans that i've read about
which is maybe
both from the standpoint of career and
even for some people from the standpoint
of relationship there would be
more more chapters or you would plan on
more chapters maybe that than people
plan on now let me ask about a couple of
other kind of finer point things
in the longevity circles there's a lot
of talk about the possibility of drugs
specific medications
providing uh additional lifespan often
the diabetes medication metformin is
mentioned
what is the what is the the real data on
metformin as a longevity drug
so um
whole issue is that aging is not
considered as disease today so there is
no regulatory framework for someone to
launch metformin study
which would test
particular outcome of taking midform in
a regular basis for your longevity and
this is where we are today i do think
that you know all of us will have an
opportunity to invest more time and
resources into
you know improving our health span and
lifespan when regulatory change will
will happen having said that
there are so many cases in in medicine
in the history of medicine where
something has been discovered as a side
effect and apparently this is what
happened with metformin so it's clear
that for certain portion of population
certain age and and relation to diabetes
metformin adds two three four years uh
to the life span and health span
well the question is whether it works
only for people who are in a particular
risk
group
like suffering from diabetes or it works
for the general population and this is
still the question that we need to
resolve so that's why i'm on the board
of american federation of aging research
and we working on the trial it's a huge
trial to be launched hopefully next year
in the u.s
under fda
approval and guidance where 3000 people
will be taking metformin and we'll have
more data in three five years from now
whether we have a new class of drugs
which
which is looking at and focusing at
aging and its core
or
metformin is a great diabetes drug but
unfortunately it doesn't really have
any you know particular positive
lifespan extension effect on the other
parts of population so it's very
promising but as everything in medicine
we well let's just test this before we
embrace the idea of of looking at me
forum so that's why you know everything
i talk about in the near horizon of
longevity 5 10 15 years from now i'm
always saying guys be conservative
unless you've been advised by your
doctor to take it and it says you have a
critical condition well let's just wait
stay on longevity breach for five 10
years and so then we can embr embrace
and and use these technologies and their
scientific discoveries in much more
responsible and less risky way yeah that
seems eminently reasonable uh and if
people google metformin longevity they
will find a lot of hyperbole that does
not yet match as you're pointing out the
data very important um life expectancy
over the last few years
is actually down slightly in the united
states and of course we're in a pandemic
that has on average slightly reduced
life expectancy we have big disparity
based on economic situation in the
united states
when you're looking longer term at
longevity what do you make of this
short-term reduction in life expectancy
so it's clearly a u.s problem
we i haven't seen any other developed
nation on this planet which would show
this um
very difficult and i say it with a lot
of love right uh
this
uh tragic situation with life expectancy
i mean it's smaller number it's decrease
of 0.2 years right every year and it's
happened in
the last three years out of five
pre-pandemic
so the reasons being is
is something needs to change in in the
healthcare sector in u.s u.s has the
most expensive
18 percent of gdp and the most
inefficient health care system in the
world
uk united kingdom um spends eight
percent of its gdp on health care and
has much better results like singapore
spend five percent of their uh budget
gdp on healthcare and uh they're on
number one or number two place in the
world health span wise and lifespan wise
together with japan so something needs
to change and and obviously this huge
impact of opioid crisis
to this number so if we will localize
this problem it's going to be better but
obviously there are a number of
fundamental problems like with obesity
with the diet of americans with
um you know
high degree and and and and intensity of
antibiotics in the in the meat and fish
etc so
having said that there's a light in the
end of the tunnel because
the medicine of the future is going to
be much more technology driven and uh
based on data so that's why i'm bracing
you know a lot of wearables which are
coming to our life wearables is not a
convenience device for you anymore and
it doesn't matter whether it's feedback
whoop or apple watch or oring does not
matter it's going to be our personalized
healthcare device and the change in
healthcare will come from new players
doing completely new things this is
where i see the
solution to the car and crisis in in the
medicine well two of the really two of
the things you talk about that i love
because so many
longevity investors
really don't talk about it are number
one
we we have to make life such that people
want to extend it number one that's very
very important i'm glad you mentioned
that and then number two
there are economic questions about
access and you seem to be addressing
both in the book which i think is great
thank you david yeah it's very important
like in the u.s you know two zip codes
next to each other had 15 years
of difference in their lifespan i i
couldn't find even you know logical or
rational explanation behind that you
know a part of inequality
uh gap that we have in this world i mean
it's and the u.s is not an exception
like in london uh you know this same
situation will give you in some of the
cases 17 1 7 years difference well
that's why i'm embracing technology
we're investing in technology to
democratize access to health care like
decreasing the cost of cancer diagnostic
by two uh five ten times decreasing the
cost of ultrasound diagnostic by ten
times and this is real numbers from
these startups that we funded uh or
decreasing the cost of um uh organ
transportation like clearer
transportation by ten times so i'm very
hopeful that
this will give us an opportunity for all
of us to be as brave as
thinking of healthcare as a basic good
and basic service which would need to be
provided to everyone for free of charge
this is my dream
the book is the science and technology
of growing young we've been speaking
with the book's author sergey young
sergey so great having you on i really
appreciate it
thank you david stay healthy and happy
please